de lo que vamos a hablar en este vídeo
es algo de lo que yo considero uno de
los temas más fascinantes en toda la
biología y es esta variación que vemos
de especies especies en el ciclo de la
vida en la esperanza de vida y en la
tasa de reproducción por ejemplo aquí
tenemos tres especies diferentes la
primera está de aquí es un elefante
africano y el elefante africano ustedes
pueden saber que vive mucho tiempo
especialmente en la naturaleza ellos
pueden vivir décadas hasta 40 o 50 o 60
años y sus ciclos de vida en realidad
son muy semejantes a los ciclos de vida
de los seres humanos al menos a los
ciclos de vida de los seres humanos
modernos porque por ejemplo los primeros
10 años de sus vidas son muy
dependientes de sus padres
después de eso entran como en un periodo
de adolescencia muy parecido a como lo
hace el ser humano donde en teoría
podrían reproducirse pero no tienden a
hacerlo y siguen siendo un poco
dependientes
después avanzan a una fase en la cual se
reproducen y se van a reproducir
aproximadamente una vez cada dos a
cuatro años se van a reproducir cada dos
a cuatro años y esto es porque su
periodo de gestación es decir la
cantidad de tiempo que el bebé elefante
estará en el vientre de su madre es
aproximadamente bueno en realidad es más
largo que los seres humanos para los
humanos probablemente sepan son de nueve
meses mientras que en un elefante
africano es de 22 meses y por esta razón
se pueden reproducir cerca de una vez
cada dos a cuatro años ahora vamos al
siguiente ejemplo que tal vez para
ustedes van a decir bueno el elefante
africano y el conejo no están realmente
muy estrechamente relacionados pero en
realidad están muy estrechamente
relacionados si piensan en todo el árbol
de la vida
ambos son mamíferos y en realidad todo
lo que estamos considerando aquí estos
tres son animales vamos a considerar a
los
africanos también a los conejos y al
salmón pero de lo que estoy hablando
aplica para toda la vida
aplica para las bacterias aplica para
los árboles y de hecho hay una enorme
variación en su fecundidad de una
especie a otra es decir la fecundidad es
la tasa en la que se reproducen déjame
notar esa palabra es importante así que
lo voy a poner con este color fecundidad
la fecundidad es decir la tasa en la que
se reproducen va a variar en los
periodos de vida estamos hablando de un
árbol o una bacteria o un peso o un
mamífero pero bueno regresando a esta
idea de los mamíferos vamos a hablar
ahora de los conejos y bueno dependiendo
de qué tipo de conejo estemos hablando
su esperanza de vida está en años que no
alcanzan más que un solo dígito por eso
lo puse aquí pero a diferencia del
elefante el elefante sus primeros 10 15
o 20 años de su vida
están en una fase reproductiva mientras
que el conejo entra a la fase
reproductiva de su vida solamente cuando
cumple algunos meses cuando pasan 4 o 5
meses nacido entonces ya está entrando a
una fase reproductiva y justo observa
estoy mostrando la fase reproductiva de
este color magenta aquí lo tengo
entonces una vez que entran a esta fase
reproductiva observa se puede reproducir
un montón eso quiere decir que tienen
una alta fecundidad tienen una tasa
reproductiva muy alta cada vez que un
conejo hembra me tiene una camada puede
tener muchos conejos y de hecho el
número que encontré fue de 1 a 14
conejos por cada camada así que déjame
anotarlo de 1
12 conejos pequeños conejos por cada
camada y esto es impresionante porque
pueden tener esta cantidad de conejos
una vez al mes entonces de 1 a 14
conejos al mes
al mes además de que observan esto lo
pueden seguir haciendo durante un largo
periodo de vida y bueno dependiendo del
tipo del conejo del que estamos hablando
pueden ser tres o cinco o seis años
dependiendo de la especie
pero bueno pueden imaginarse que si se
están produciendo no sean digamos diez
conejos por mes entonces entonces meses
tendríamos 120 conejos 120 conejos
durante un año y si se pueden reproducir
durante 35 46 años qué sé yo
imagínate la cantidad de conejos que
pueden producir y no sólo eso imagínate
que la mitad de estos conejos que acaban
de nacer son hembras y si estás
conejitas pueden llegar muy rápidamente
a la fase reproductiva entonces van a
empezar a producir con una tasa similar
eso quiere decir que primero a un nivel
individual un conejo hembra tiene una
fecundidad muy
pero a un nivel de población este grupo
de conejos también tiene una fecundidad
muy muy alta y bueno podemos ver ahora
el otro ejemplo vamos a compararlo con
el salmón hay muchos tipos de salmón
pero el ciclo de la vida
general por el que pasa el salmón es que
ellos nacen generalmente nacen en un
arroyo y casi siempre en algún lugar
donde el agua no tenga mucha corriente y
una vez que las crías de salmón nacen
pueden nacer en grupos de cientos o
miles y ellos hacen su camino por ese
río por ese arroyo hasta el océano y
luego tienen muchos años de una etapa de
crecimiento en el océano donde se hacen
más y más y más grandes y fuertes en ese
momento no se están reproduciendo y
luego cuando están listos para
reproducirse lo que hacen es luchar para
regresar al mismo arroyo o al mismo río
donde nacieron van a hacer su camino de
regreso
entonces luchan en su camino de regreso
llegan hasta arriba de ese río o
desarrollo y ahí se reproducen y bueno
se reproducen cuando las hembras ponen
los huevos y los machos 2 fertilizan y
luego ellos mueren así que observan
solamente tienen un evento reproductivo
déjame escribirlo en este caso tenemos
solamente un evento reproductivo
suben todo el río se reproducen y
después mueren y hasta ahorita la gente
no entiende por qué pasa esto que de
hecho esto recibe un nombre técnico las
especies que hacen esto y digo las
especies porque el salmón no es el único
que le pasa esto mismo donde solamente
tenemos un evento reproductivo y ojo en
este evento reproductivo pueden tener
cientos o miles de huevos y después
mueren después de esto muere
ya esto se le conoce con el nombre de
semen paridad
se me viene del latín que significa una
vez en paridad también viene del latín
que significa engendrar entonces en
general una vez que estás reproduciendo
una sola vez y bueno luego en el caso
del salmón mueres y seguramente puedes
decir bueno si el salmón tiene a sem el
paridad entonces cómo se llaman cuando
puedes reproducir más de una vez por
ejemplo en los conejos o bueno tal vez
un poco más claro en los elefantes y
bueno a esto se le llama hetero paridad
así que lo voy a escribir y te lo
paridad seguramente has escuchado la
palabra literal que significa repetir
algo o hacer algo varias veces y es que
el iter um es la raíz que significa en
repetir entonces pero paridad es
engendrar repetidamente y eso es algo
que hacen los elefantes y más
seguramente los conejos y bueno lo
fascinante acerca de todo esto que de
hecho es una pregunta que
ha estado analizando desde la primera
vez que vi este tema es porque hay tanta
variación aquí es decir porque la
selección natural tienen estos ciclos de
vida y de reproducción tan diferentes o
dicho de otra manera estas tasas de
reproducción tan diferentes o esta
variación en la fecundidad o porque
algunos organismos tienen inter paridad
y otros tienen semen paridad bueno
realmente esto no es un misterio hay
mucha gente estudiando esto y tienen muy
buenas hipótesis pero todavía no lo
sabemos con seguridad y un esquema que
tal vez te podría ayudar a entender esto
mejor es pensar que bueno una especie
está tratando de optimizar su
supervivencia y ni siquiera la
supervivencia del individuo está
tratando de optimizar la supervivencia
de su información genética y bueno tal
vez no estás diciendo ok las especies o
los genes no lo están intentando se de
tal cual no de una forma activa
pero así podremos pensarlo como la
selección natural está haciendo eso para
ellos así que a este 4 de aquí le vamos
a llamar la selección natural y por lo
tanto la salida de este cuadro que tengo
aquí van a ser genes más aptos entonces
déjame ponerlo
cuando hablamos de genes más aptos no
estamos hablando de que haya genes
mejores que otros sólo estamos diciendo
que para ese ambiente los genes que
producen los rasgos que son más aptos
para la supervivencia o más aptos para
la reproducción son estos y luego vamos
a pensar aquí en las entradas y bueno
van a ser cosas como la disposición de
energía de alimento lo que yo llamo
energía libre entonces déjame ponerlo la
disponibilidad de energía libre ya que
obviamente no solamente las plantas
pueden obtener energía libre del sol
entonces disponibilidad de energía de
alimento también nos van a preocupar
el ambiente predatorio es decir que no
nos coman
y bueno claro también nos va a preocupar
que tengamos salud por lo tanto podemos
hablar de enfermedades
entonces en cada momento un organismo
que esté vivo tiene que preocuparse por
esto tiene que preocuparse por encontrar
alimento o por competir por alimento
tiene que preocuparse por los
depredadores y tiene que preocuparse por
las enfermedades bueno de nuevo un
organismo tal vez de una manera
individual no necesariamente este salmón
está sentado ahí diciendo oh espero que
no contraer una enfermedad tal vez ni
siquiera se angustia por los osos que
podría intentar agarrarlos mientras van
contracorriente pero estos son los
factores que participan en la selección
natural o al menos creo que esa es la
mejor manera de expresar lo y ahora si
nos fijamos en términos desde el punto
de vista de las especies
entonces los diferentes estilos que van
a tener en su reproducción dadas estas
restricciones son fecundidad déjame
ponerlo con el color que lo puse ese
ratón fecundidad es decir la tasa de
reproducción y bueno también tenemos
cosas como la edad de reproducción
o también tenemos cosas como la
esperanza de vida
o cosas tan sencillas como el
crecimiento
y la salud y es que una especie un
organismo está haciendo intercambios
todo el tiempo
ustedes saben estos salmones van a
través de esa enorme fase donde se
decide aplicar la mayor de su energía
para el crecimiento y su supervivencia y
después de repente entran a otra fase
donde en realidad se va a usar la mayor
cantidad de energía almacenada para ir
contracorriente y pasar a una fase
reproductiva y luego morir y la
selección natural de cierta forma hace
este tipo de cosas tal vez esto sucede
porque de alguna manera ayuda al adn del
salmón a propagarse más o tal vez alguna
manera agrega nutrientes al agua o pone
toda esa energía para ir contracorriente
para que después su descendencia vaya de
una manera más fácil a favor de la
corriente pero también hay otros
intercambios por ejemplo un salmón
hembra puede poner miles de huevos pero
muy pocos de ellos en realidad pasan por
el ciclo completo
las estimaciones que he visto son que de
esos miles de huevos que ponen la hembra
del salmón bueno solamente regresan 3
aproximadamente sólo regresan 3 salmones
de nuevo a poner sus huevos eso fue lo
que vimos acerca del salmón rojo en
promedio sólo tres de ellos regresan
para el siguiente año así que tienen una
gran cantidad de pérdida de energía o
tal vez podría decir de cansancio
mientras que en el caso del elefante
asiático invierten más por cría y tienen
una probabilidad más alta de que cada
una de esas crías sobrevivan así que hay
de todo tipo de intercambios
interesantes para pensar cuando hablamos
acerca del ciclo de la vida y también
cosas como fecundidad y cómo se
reproducen los organismos